nancy capital international de
l'organisation mondiale de la santé a
choisi la capitale lorraine comme
partenaire nancy eux c'est le nom de ce
centre qui avait été créée en 84 on vous
prête 350 chercheurs
alors durant quatre ans dans plusieurs
pays européens
nancy va devoir traquer et les microbes
dans l'eau potable est surprenante l'eau
et nancy une alliance naturelle après un
passé de stations thermales la vie est
devenue l'un des grands pôles
internationaux de la recherche sur l'eau
et l'assainissement à l'origine dans ci
a bénéficié d'un certain nombre d'atouts
importants
la proximité de grandes écoles de
chercheurs et des entreprises comme la
lyonnaise des eaux la cge ou
pont-à-mousson un potentiel conséquent
qui a débouché en 1984 sur la création
du centre international de l'eau nancy
dans le secteur recherche 22 études sont
en cours avec un dénominateur commun
l'assainissement de l'eau parmi elles
biofilm une histoire d'eau ambitieuse
qui vise à terme améliorer la qualité de
l'eau potable
à l'aide de cette maquette de réseaux de
distribution 25 chercheurs et trois
laboratoires examine quotidiennement la
dégradation de l'eau qui stationnent où
circulent dans ses tuyaux
tous les jours on regarde justement la
croissance bactérienne qui se développe
sur ces petites surfaces que nous avons
dans des éprouvettes selon de la
canalisation
on étudie le nombre la qualité des
gemmes bactérienne qui sont présents et
ça nous permet d'avoir les simulations
d'un réseau en réel et devant
l'évolution bactérienne qui est cause
d'une certaine dégradation de la qualité
des eaux des études qui intéresse aussi
directement le consommateur d'eau du
robinet à bientôt l'eau plus potable que
potable